what the [__]
are you degenerates doing research
for what we're doing what is a weeb
oh there's no chance of that happening i
would never
you'd have a better chance of me doing
anime is intrinsically tied to esports
culture
no matter how much time passes no matter
how much the esports audience ages
no matter how much i can't stand the
stuff the two are inseparable
it gives me passion it's like a great
anime battle you know like
[__] like oh man like whenever
sasuke betrayed naruto why did he do it
why did he do it to test his abilities
and to unlock the sharding gun
i have no idea what you're talking about
but i assume it's very hype for all you
weebs out there
however what you might not know is the
fact that weebs have
actually been around for centuries back
in the 1800s european citizens gained
access to japanese art and culture for
the first time
through things like ukiyoe prince
brought over by merchants
the colors and aesthetics of these
pieces inspired a lot of artists and
critics of the era
eventually leading to an entire movement
known as japanism
those artists were the first weebs but
back then
people just called them japanophiles
as the years went on foreign obsession
with japanese culture made the
transition from prints
paintings and films into anime
the origin of the term weeb itself is a
bit strange though
it comes from a 2005 perry bible
fellowship comic strip called weeaboo
which has literally nothing to do with
anime the anime connection came later
that year
but it requires a bit of backtracking
just like today
it was pretty common to make fun of
people for liking anime in the early
2000s
and it happened a lot on message boards
like 4chan but before they had the term
weeb to use online trolls would call
people japanese which was short for
wannabe japanese back then it was less
about people who liked anime and more
about anyone who wasn't japanese who was
just
a little too into that culture i love
sushi
i love japan period the tea ceremony
rock yes
but the use of japanese got way out of
control
leading anime fans and trolls to go to
war all across 4chan
in the end moderators filtered the word
wapanese and replaced it with weeaboo
from the pbf comic
and by substituting japanese with
weeaboo they caused the term to become
associated with obnoxious anime fans
well you guys are obnoxious
eventually weeaboo was shortened to
weave and it slowly transformed from an
insult directed at anime fans
into one they've since embraced now
that's not to say that liking anime is
the be-all end-all of weeb-dumb
no there are far cringier ways to earn
that classification
just look at naruto runners
the waifu apologists blow up the kills
yay and whatever the hell is happening
with those
body pillows
it is here like any other object objects
are made by men and used for many
purposes
now i'm contractually obligated to tell
you that anime isn't all cringe
it's a vibrant medium that plenty of
normal people enjoy but what you may
have noticed over the past couple of
years is that it's become ingrained in
[Music]
esports
whoa i don't think we've ever seen that
before
[Applause]
ah that is better now i will be able to
move freely
come on you really think you'll be able
to get through gara's defenses
just by dropping a couple of pounds of
weight
these two guys combined work so well is
that a fusion deal
with the who passing it on
[Music]
but this infatuation isn't exclusive to
the pro scene
just think about your own matchmaking
experiences
when was the last time you played cs go
and didn't encounter someone with an
anime avatar
if you play league of legends it's more
than likely that you've shared a lobby
with some miscreant with a name like
sasuke fan 420
and how many times have you jumped into
your game of choice to find someone
spouting nihongo words or phrases
pretty good
but those references extend beyond
avatars and usernames anime is often
baked into the very games themselves
take a look at dota 2's lena the slayer
who is literally named after slayer's
character
lena league of legends takes every
chance it can to weeb up its user
experience
players can emote the harahara yukai
dance from haruhi as ezreal
represent tangent top a guran login with
rumble super galaxy skin
or pick from an entire line of star
guardian skins
that clearly referenced sailor moon
which riot even made an
anime opening for
[Music]
wait what's wrong with you people i
suspect you might have rather unusual
proclivities
first-person shooters aren't safe from
the weeaboo plague either
overwatch is pretty cartoony which makes
its litany of anime references
fit right in everyone from moira to
pharah
is loaded up with weed bait even a more
realistic
fps like cs go has the fan made but
totally usable in-game
akihabara except the only skin in the
game
that dares to ask the question what if
you put an anime girl
on a gun stock yeah yeah but your
scientists were so preoccupied with
whether or not they could they didn't
stop to think if they should
and even outside of the games themselves
we have esports orgs making anime-style
promotional art for their teams
while a number of big personalities
profess their love for the medium
i'm not even kidding i have chills right
now and gohan defeats cell with a one
arm
kamehameha and he's got his dad talking
to him from the afterlife
go on you can do this oh it's a [__]
and on top of having perhaps the
weebiest gamer tag of all time
misfits 80 carrie han sama loves manga
so much
that he even draws his own i like manga
because most of them
are pretty good stories and i really
enjoy the drawings and it makes me draw
all the time when i was here
their drawings meanwhile esports fans
will almost always refer to their
favorite moments as
so anime cloud 9's insane run from last
place to worlds
down to just bjergsen watching his
kingdom fall to ashes
so anime penta's crazy comeback against
eg at the 2018
they're 6 known as the best team in the
world never having that distinction
until today so anime
og winning ti8 after being betrayed by
one of the team's founders
[Applause]
some people in the world don't like
anime i know right it's weird
it's become so common to compare esports
events to anime
that it's occasionally been the source
of frustration for some
overwatch league caster monte cristo
made some enemies among overwatch fans
when he declared that the league is not
an anime
to which fans responded by literally
making it into one
[Music]
look i don't like anime but even i'll
admit that it's pointless to try and
stop its proliferation in esports
it's no different than using classic
movie franchises as cultural reference
points
just instead of lord of the rings it's
[__] like one piece and hunter hunter
when you think about eg dumping owie
after just winning ti5
what comes to mind is it griffith
betraying the band of the hawk
[Music]
or is it lando turning his back on han
solo and siding with the empire
i had no choice there right right before
you did
i'm sorry it's all about the media you
grew up with
themes like friendship betrayal
redemption triumph over adversity
students defeating their mentors and
mysterious heroes
are all ancient storytelling conventions
prevalent through all narrative media
anime is just the latest form to adopt
and popularize them for a new generation
of people
[Music]
at the end of the day there's no getting
rid of weebs from esports and gaming
because you can't stop people from
talking about the [__] they love
whether it's through their usernames
spamming something related to it in-game
or using it as a way to describe their
favorite moments
you know people have been wanting me to
cheer for america for years to protect
the americans this is one of my top 10
anime portrayals
you know what golden boy today's not
that day
no
[Applause]
and while it makes me sick the cult of
weave only grows larger every day
working with an office
full of them has taught me tolerance but
some days
even i can't contain my disgust for
these
filthy goddamn weeds that's right i've
been lying this entire time
i'm actually a huge anime nerd i just
didn't know how to live with myself
after finishing that trash fire that was
the third season of a certain magical
[Music]
index
[Applause]
so
[Music]
waifu sorry i'm just the back of gaijin
i don't [__] know this [__]
so anime so anime
so enemy so anime